welcome to the live stream it's been a
while great to talk to everybody going
to wait a minute or two just for people
to connect yeah it's been a while since
the last livestream I was in Las Vegas
at a conference last week and I did the
show Wednesday Thursday Friday from Las
Vegas and I was hoping to have some time
to do a stream in the evening there or
afternoon or whatever and it was just so
busy that didn't even come close to
having any time to do it so glad to be
back - it is Wednesday but this is the
first opportunity I've had and there's a
lot of news that is broken and that is
sort of in the process of breaking since
we did the show today I want to preview
some of the stories we're going to talk
about tomorrow tomorrow I predict will
be a pretty big news day and Obamacare
is part of it and the potential repeal
of Obamacare we're also going to talk
about the James Comey hearing tomorrow
we are going to talk about just a lot of
different stuff a lot of different stuff
is going to be on tomorrow's program and
the moderators are here I guess I should
go over some if this is your first live
stream and I know that for some people
it probably is not number one we're
really live I'm really sitting here
talking to you right now assuming that
it's 601 p.m. Eastern in the year 2017
the third day of May if it's any other
time then the stream is not actually
live number two super chat is on you can
use the dollar sign at the bottom of the
comment bar to send super chats super
chat questions and comments will be read
and if they're questions and if they're
reasonable questions they will also be
answered number three new members and
patrons who sign up or pledge during the
live stream will have their praises sung
by me live thank-yous and shout outs
during the stream that applies to people
signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership and people pledging even if
you just pledge $1 a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I
will still thank you and sing your
praises during the live stream we do
have moderators
monitoring the chat and obvious trolling
and hate will get you banned it is not
an infringement of your First Amendment
rights
it is not censorship it is merely that
obvious trolling and hate are really
annoying to people who are just trying
to hang and we're not going to allow it
but subtle trolling if it's subtle
enough to go unnoticed probably will not
get you banned a bunch of people emailed
me on May 1st
saying David what happened on patreon
because you lost a whole bunch of
patrons it is not a coincidence that it
was May 1st that that happened and I'll
talk about that a little bit later I am
glad to address political issues issues
about the show issues about how we're
doing with regard to me doing a show
with my hair out of control the way it
was in that Instagram picture on my
account a few weeks ago I'm glad to talk
about that stuff and we'll update people
on all of that stuff but one of the big
issues that is it were likely to have
some breaking news very very soon about
this it relates to the second attempt
from Republicans to put together
haphazardly admittedly some kind of
replacement to the Affordable Care Act
and there have been there's been no
shortage of failures for the Trump
administration so far we've had the two
failed majority Muslim country
immigration bans uh is it fair to call
it a Muslim ban I consider Muslim ban
short for majority Muslim country
immigration ban so while it is not in
the literal sense a Muslim ban it is
effectively a band that is going to
disproportionately and deliberately
impact and target people who are Muslim
in any case two attempts from Trump on
that both have failed Trump sanctuary
city executive order nope blocked by
courts first attempt from Trump and
Republicans in some combination which
depending on who you ask different
proportions that we can attribute to
each failed failed miserably house
freedom caucus wouldn't get behind
obviously Democrats wouldn't get behind
it long list of other failures which we
won't rehash right now and where we are
right now is that we are very very close
to hearing whether the house can get a
majority 50% plus one votes for the
second iteration of the potential
replacement to Obamacare the goal of
course being to repeal Obamacare and the
latest that I've read is that
Republicans are moving in the direction
of uniting behind this and that there
may be a yes 50 plus percent vote in the
House of Representatives we will see by
no means is is that yes vote if it
happens an indicator that we are
definitively going to see that bill this
bill that bill call it what you will
become the law of the land it's still of
course has to pass the Senate and then
it has to be signed by the President and
I assume the president will sign it but
we'll see what ultimately happens in the
in the Senate and a number of questions
there with regard to many aspects
including pre-existing conditions and
there's this complete weasel approach
that we're seeing from Republicans on
this thing where they have up included
certain provisions in this six second
iteration of their health care bill that
we're not in the first iteration but
have also included the possibility of
individual states getting a waiver to
wait out of having to abide by those
provisions and this is just so easily
and it's really bottom of the barrel you
know gutter politics pre-existing
conditions is one example where under
the Affordable Care Act you are not
allowed to just charge astronomically
high rates or reject people from
coverage if they they are seeking
coverage at a time when they have what
is called a pre-existing condition and
many people think of really really acute
illness in those cases but we're also
talking about more chronic illness that
is pre-existing conditions and and when
you consider that we're really talking
about a lot of people here nearly half
of all insured individuals have some
kind of pre-existing condition
to some degree so you say okay we're
going to include the provision that says
you you've got to give reasonably priced
coverage to people with pre-existing
conditions but states can opt out of
that through a waiver system so are you
really including it if people can opt
out of it not really and and it's this
exact type of thing which really exposes
the fundamental corruption of our system
I mean it's really a vile and corrupt
system that other countries at our level
of development and many countries below
our level of development have already
figured out that this for-profit system
is not a system that makes sense and I'm
not going to start doing a rant now
about single-payer health care and and I
mean most of you probably know how I
feel about this at this point and if
you're going to say well David small
countries can do that the u.s. is big
and it can't do it that's absolutely
been debunked and it's not true if
you're going to say well David the tax
rates in some of those countries are
just exponentially higher than in the
United States now in many countries that
the tax rates are higher but when you
consider that it includes college
education and healthcare and the mere
concept of having to keep a job you hate
just not to lose health insurance
doesn't exist I believe that it would be
a pretty worthwhile trade-off and this
is coming from someone who you know I've
looked at the Trump tax plan to the
extent that it's a tax plan and it's a
page of weirdly vaunted meaningless
bullet points but to the extent that we
can call it a plan it's a plan that
would see my taxes reduced pretty
significantly through this provision
that that Trump has suggested where
pass-through income income earned by a
business entity that passes through to
be paid at the individual tax return
level the david pakman show is held by
an S corporation so a lot of my income
yearly is coming from what's called the
business distribution I would see a
reduction in all of that income to only
15% federal tax rate I stand to benefit
financially from what much of Trump is
doing that doesn't mean it makes any
sense and that doesn't mean that I'm
supportive of it and it doesn't mean
that I'm that I'm going to say that it's
a good idea Mira
because I would benefit personally from
it so it's you know just because I have
health insurance doesn't mean that I'm
going to say oh yeah taxes are just too
high in other countries and it wouldn't
work for the United States I'm really
trying to look at this from from the
broadest possible perspective so we will
see the latest I'm been looking as I've
been getting ready to to jump on the
live stream let's see if there's any
more breaking news
still nothing still nothing definitive
about the potential replacement to the
Affordable Care Act okay I want to
address this recent Jimmy Kimmel video
let me actually just deal with the first
Super chat just because it's a simple
thing and then we'll get back to this
Cherise Walker sent a $5 super chat
saying hey David do you need any help
with mods etc Trump fans are being
obviously obtuse when they don't see
it's a Muslim ban you know we have a
bunch of moderators five or six or
something like that who I think are
handling the situation pretty well but
that doesn't mean we can't have more
moderators so Cherise if you want to get
in touch through the contact form in the
at david pakman.com click on contact us
and email me we can we can certainly
look at that I mean it's never you know
that the live streams happen at
different times of day and we've got
moderators in a variety of different
time zones so it's not a bad thing to
have more moderators okay
let me move on to what do I want to do
next they're just so I want to talk
about the Jimmy Kimmel thing I want to
talk about the James Comey hearing I've
got thank-yous accumulating and then I
want to update you on the YouTube
boycott so let's start with the Jimmy
Kimmel thing okay so Jimmy Kimmel hosts
a late-night show on ABC sandwiched at
least on my cable system between CBS and
NBC is Jimmy Kimmel I generally find
Jimmy Kimmel show to be funny I don't
watch it off and I'm actually rarely up
late enough to watch any of those shows
at this point I used to be up all the
time when Conan O'Brien was on at 12:35
a.m. Eastern I don't even know what I
was doing I would just be up watching
these shows but anyway I go to bed much
earlier now but Jimmy Kimmel has a video
that has gone viral where he
is I believe it's his second child or at
least his second child with his current
wife or you know I don't know that much
about his personal life but his most
recently born child a son had a heart
issue and needed surgery and Jimmy
Kimmel in a very emotional video that
now has millions upon millions of views
made an emotional appeal to the
political establishment not being
overtly pro-democratic and anti
Republican but clearly the message was
one that would align more with the views
of democratic elected officials than
Republicans saying no one should ever
have to go through what I went through
but effectively be unsure if they're
going to be able to afford getting their
kid the treatment that they need and the
reactions to this have been incredibly
varied and I I don't know you know I'll
tell you what my feelings are about this
and I genuinely don't know if it's going
to resonate with everybody because
listen on the one hand from a personal
level how could I possibly disagree with
Jimmy Kimmel I've been an advocate of a
single-payer health care system for a
very long time or a universal health
insurance system or something
approximating what other countries at
our level of development have and I
could not possibly agree more with Jimmy
Kimmel that we we it is immoral given
the wealth of the United States to have
a situation where people have to make
financial decisions or rather medical
decisions based on finances when we're
talking about life or death situations
it's absolutely horrible that being said
I wonder whether personal anecdotes are
the best way to argue in favor of or
against any particular policy and I want
to try to think this through with you
and be as consistent as possible let's
deal with the example of the death
penalty right I'm against the death
penalty I believe that the United States
that no country should have a death
I've talked about everything related to
sort of the morality of it
the eye-for-an-eye aspect of it the fact
that it is you know we can imagine a
world where it's carried out only when
it is actually guilty individuals but we
know that there are people on death row
who are not guilty I've said that if you
want the worst possible punishment I
think that it's actually worse to have
to sit in jail for the rest of your life
in prison for the rest of your life and
to have the lights turned off so in any
way any way you slice it I'm against the
death penalty that being said I can
imagine a situation where if a loved one
of mine was killed I would feel that the
death penalty was warranted in this
particular case that doesn't mean that
public policy should be made based on
what my feelings would be in a highly
emotional state okay if I apply that
same logic to the health care thing the
story Jimmy Kimmel told is absolutely
horrible I hope that it connects with
enough people that it will activate
people to start calling the
representatives and advocating for
something better than what we have
rather than something worse but in
general I believe that we should not be
making policy decisions based on
individual stories and how one
individual may feel this does not deal
Aegina my's anything that Jimmy Kimmel
said this is not to argue that I would
be feeling any differently the Jimmy
Kimmel was if I was in the same
situation but I wish that we could have
more people engaging with this issue not
based on anecdotal stories but based on
the broader realities that bankruptcy
because of health expenses shouldn't be
something that we have in the United
States period I'm not mad at Jimmy
Kimmel I don't think Jimmy Kimmel is a
bad person but but that's sort of my
general feeling about that and I'm
curious curious what other people think
about that okay so those are my thoughts
on the Jimmy Kimmel thing let me do a
couple thank-yous here okay for people
that have been signing up and pledging
while we've been talking here number one
patreon patreon.com slash david pakman
show is one of the two platforms where
individuals can contribute to the
production costs of our show okay while
we've been chatting here p.m. Paul has
made $1 pledge at patreon.com slash
david pakman show as well as tim hess
who has made a $2 pledge at patreon.com
slash david pakman show now some people
will see this and they'll see
wait a second David 1472 patrons you
were over 1500 patrons last month and
well on your way to the 2,000 patron
goal and you would indeed be right about
that however what happens on the 1st of
every month is patreon makes an attempt
to collect everybody's pledges and
unfortunately what happens is that
between the pledge date and the 1st of
the following month many people's credit
cards expire many people's debit cards
get declined and as a result on the 1st
of every single month there is a
reduction a tightening up a correction
to use a stock market term in both the
number of patrons and the total amount
pledged so we're back to we were at like
15 30 or 15 40 at the end of last month
we're back to targeting 1500 patrons ok
and of course this is all to replace the
lost revenue from the YouTube advertiser
boycott which I will talk about more and
if we do make it to 2000 individual
patrons it doesn't matter whether you
contribute one a hundred or a thousand
dollars per month I will do an entire
show in studio with my hair like this
this is what happens when I do not use
product in my hair it becomes a very
very scary situation and a few viewer
suggested hey David what about doing
some kind of target where you will do a
show in studio like that and I said
absolutely gladly if we get to 2,000
patrons I'll do a whole show like this
so patreon.com slash david pakman show I
also have a couple of new members to
thank who have signed up during the show
Clemens hug has signed up at
pakman.com slash membership Clemens has
chosen to use the 40% coupon code I
voted 17 and I appreciate that
very very much also how do I pronounce
this ha Hawk or haki Hess has signed up
at david pakman.com slash membership and
John Schultz has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership using the
coupon code
I voted 17 very easy to use the coupon
code you go to david pakman.com slash
membership you select the membership of
your choice either monthly or yearly and
you hit that red signup button that will
take you to the second page of the
signup process and as you can see there
under the coupon code field you can
enter
I voted 17 and that will give you a 40%
discount those are the two main funding
sources for the show and I will update
you on what's going on in terms of the
YouTube advertiser boycott in a little
bit ok so now that we've gotten that out
of the way let me talk about the Hillary
Clinton video Hillary Clinton did a
public appearance about 24 hours ago 30
hours ago something like that and in it
she talked about why she lost the
presidential election and in this video
she simultaneously said I take
responsibility for having lost this
election at the same time were it not
for Russian hacking and FBI director
James Comey choosing on I believe the
date was October 28th to talk about the
investigation into her emails that she
would have won and Hillary Clinton is
getting slammed by a ton of people for
this and I think that there are
legitimate critiques but there is also
legitimacy to what Hillary Clinton said
Trump was such an abortive and atrocious
and vile candidate that someone with
Hillary Clinton's experience and
knowledge should never have even been in
a tight race with Trump right so in the
end Donald Trump won because of 77
modes across three swing states should
77,000 votes across three swing states
have swung the election the answer is
obviously no and part of it is Hillary
Clinton was so hampered as a candidate
by the the you know everything from the
email scandal to what I would consider
an uninspiring economic message Trump's
an economic message was ludicrous but it
at least tricked people obviously none
of it's happening now I mean nothing
that Trump said he was going to do as
far as economics is happening but
Hillary Clinton's economic message was
was disastrous
we had the DNC involved with their
fingers on the scale or their hands on
the scale or whatever you want to call
it in favor of Hillary Clinton and
against Bernie Sanders so there's no
doubt in my mind that when you're
talking about 77,000 votes across three
key states that if it were not for James
commis antics as well as Russian
attempts at - I believe at least
partially slightly pushed the election
in one direction that Hillary Clinton
would have won that being said it never
should have been that close Bernie
Sanders got screwed by the DNC and I you
know how do we parse it how do we
separate it out I don't think anything
Hillary Clinton said is wrong and she
says she's taking personal
responsibility the truth is never should
have been this close it really never
should have been this close and you know
as far as Bernie voters are concerned
there was some concern six months before
the election or I guess not not six
months but two to three months before
the election that some significant
portion of Bernie voters were not going
to ultimately vote for Hillary Clinton
most did most did and my sense is that
the percentage that didn't in
Pennsylvania Wisconsin and Michigan
North Carolina that you know these
states would not have actually flipped
the election over to Hillary Clinton
would not did not flip it to Donald
Trump or wouldn't
I flipped to Hillary Clinton but I've
not actually seen a full analysis of
that so we're going to dig into the
Hillary Clinton video on the program
tomorrow
chase Lawrence has sent a five-dollar
super chat David I'm 16 thanks to people
like you I've learned much about
politics and have begun applying to
journalism internships thanks for
inspiring me well thank you really
really appreciate that chase and
appreciate the the super chat and you
know we have internships at the David
Pakman show we actually are in the
process right now of interviewing people
for the summer session if you're going
to be in the Boston area and have the
ability to spend a couple days a week in
our studio by all means feel free to
apply through the contact form at david
pakman.com we've had it we've had a
really good string of interns now going
back several years and part of it is
that there's lots of really smart people
that watch the show and want to
participate part of it I must say is
that I am slightly better now than I
used to be at discerning who might do a
good job as an intern I think early on
there might have been you know some
decisions made with regard to to interns
that ended up with not the best fits but
it's a learning process and you know I
think it's something that we've been
improving upon and for years now there
have been just good intern after good
intern so I think that's really really
great I'm having sort of like two
instances of my streaming software and I
hope that it's not causing a problem for
anybody this is everything look okay I
think it does uh yeah it looks okay so
let me give you an update on the YouTube
advertiser boycott okay this is
something that it's this has been going
on since March 31st and I want to talk a
little bit about it okay so as you know
the david pakman show is on youtube
you're watching a YouTube livestream
right now and on YouTube we typically we
have ads that play before YouTube videos
and this is how we make money on YouTube
and over the years YouTube has been
become a pretty big revenue source for
us so as of the end of March we were
earning anywhere from forty to fifty
percent of our revenue
from YouTube ads and because of a Wall
Street Journal article that came out I
guess it was about a week five five to
seven days I think before March 31st
which basically raised the alarm saying
oh my god there are major company ads
like coca-cola whose ads are appearing
in front of just racist and horrible
content on YouTube YouTube's got a major
problem they can't control where their
ads are appearing they've got to clamp
down and do something so on March 31st
YouTube turned on a new advertising
algorithm which determines when should
an ad play before a video and with the
snap of a finger or the flip of the
switch David Pakman show YouTube revenue
went down somewhere between 98 and 99
point 8 percent I mean it was down to
you know pennies pennies a day and this
was a big problem for us this was a
major problem because as a business to
you know we were lucky enough that we
weren't completely reliant on YouTube
revenue but our YouTube channel has been
doing pretty well we're approaching four
hundred thousand subscribers we've got
anywhere from 8 to 15 million views per
month on the YouTube channel and thus we
instantly lost 40 to 50 percent of our
revenue now this isn't just some show
that we do in a basement right we have
staff we have a proper studio in an
office building we have the expectation
of us from 200 radio and television
stations and DirecTV and Dish Network
Monday through Friday that we're going
to deliver our program to them at a
particular time etc so this was
effectively a crisis and as a result we
started talking more about how important
it is to contribute through membership
and we launched the patreon at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
uh we essentially earned no money on
YouTube other than super chat revenue
and a little bit from YouTube red
between March 31st and April 11th okay
April 11th we saw a little bit of a bump
a few ads returned here and there and we
had a couple days April 11th and 12th
where we've read you know
were up to like 12 or 15 percent of our
prior YouTube ad revenue and then the
day after April 13th falls off a cliff
and basically our entire vacation great
timing on my part we planned our
vacation months ago my entire vacation I
was dealing with YouTube and trying to
figure out how to replace this revenue
because it dropped back completely off
the face of the earth almost no revenue
whatsoever
what's going on right now a lot of
people have been emailing me saying
David I'm seeing ads on your channel I'm
seeing a lot of ads on your channel is
the YouTube ad boycott fixed and that's
what I want to talk about right now so
there's basically two metrics that are
important here okay how many ads play
and how much do the ads pay right those
are sort of the two questions I've
previously said that each ad we usually
see something like a fifth of a penny
front okay so for each ad you watch we
get 1/5 of a penny doesn't sound like
much but when you've got a lot of ads
playing every single day in every single
month it can really add up so right now
we have ads playing big picture on 4 out
of every 10 videos okay you might be
seeing more ads than that you might be
seeing no ads whatsoever but in total
we've got 40% monetization so for every
10 views on average for ads play how
does that compare to before the ad
boycott before the ad boycott we were
somewhere in the range of 6 ads for
every 10 video so when you look at that
it doesn't look bad right we've seen a
one-third drop we still have two-thirds
of the ads playing that we're playing
before and that's true but the other
factor that is absolutely crushing us is
that we have what I can only describe as
really low quality ads playing okay
YouTube divides ads into roughly five
different types but there's two major
types of ads one type of ad is called
auction ads the other type of ad is
called
Reserve at the word is escaping me here
so auction ads are sort of lower quality
ads and reserve ads are the higher
quality ads the reserve ads pay anywhere
from fifty to a hundred percent more
than the auction ads prior to the crisis
we had about a 50/50 split fifty percent
auction ads fifty percent reserve ads we
now have two percent reserve ads not
twenty two percent reserve ads so
effectively we have two thirds of the
quantity of ads playing as before and on
average each ad is paying about half as
much so simple math thinking back to
third grade and multiplications of
fractions two-thirds times one half is
one-third so right now we have a youtube
channel that's generating about
one-third of the revenue that it was
generating over the last year year and a
half so what's the upside the upside is
it's not zero when we were looking at a
ninety nine percent reduction in ad
revenue then that was a very different
situation than what we have right now
one third is still pretty bad and we
still have to make up that money and so
as a result we're doing a couple of
different things one thing that we're
doing is again I mentioned this before
I'll mention it one more time now in the
context of the ad boycott we have a
patreon page and the patreon page is
it's not membership it's just super
super straightforward all it is is you
pledge $1 a month
you pledge $2 a month whatever amount
you want and this basically helps to
recover the lost ad revenue we estimated
that from each YouTube viewer if you
watched every single one of our ads we
would get about 35 cents maybe from you
over the course of a month if you just
throw in a dollar then you are making up
for that and more and the immediate goal
is 1500 patrons we would like to
eventually get to 2000 so that's one
thing that we're doing
the other thing we're doing is we're
talking about the importance of
membership okay and membership has been
around for at this point something like
seven years we've got members that have
been with us for seven years we've had
members that have been with us for just
a few minutes right the people that I
thanked for signing up during the stream
and that can happen at david pakman.com
slash membership it's more involved than
patreon there are members only benefits
there's a Members Only show you create
and use a username and password on our
website so it's a little bit more
involved but it comes with more perks
then does patreon pledging so you can do
either you can do both and you can use
the coupon code
I voted 17 on our website to get a 40%
discount I think that the normal rates
for membership are very very reasonable
six bucks a month when you consider that
we do 160 to 180 videos per month I
think it's pretty good and worth every
penny but you can save 40% by using the
coupon code
I voted 17 and you still get 100% of the
benefits so to everybody and we've had
you know between membership and patreon
we've had a couple thousand people get
involved during the last just over a
month at this point of the YouTube
advertiser boycott and I want to send a
big thank you to all of those people and
in particular I want to thank right now
Ryan Copley has pledged $2 at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
jim has just pledged $5 at patreon.com
slash david pakman show also Laura
Plains has signed up for membership at
david pakman.com slash membership and I
want to thank Laura as well okay I see
there's a bunch of people spamming the
chat saying answer la de [ __ ] question
it seems that somebody is interested
that a number of people are interested
in me answering this person's question I
can't find the question and I don't know
what it is so if someone can tell me
what the question is I'm not avoiding
questions from the regular chat and only
focusing on super chat it's just very
difficult with the speed at which
a which the chat is moving I genuinely
don't know what that question is so what
what is the question can anybody explain
to me what what a [ __ ] question is who
is that person if anybody can tell me
what the question is I will gladly
answer it okay why do people pick and
choose when execution is worse than
prison forever
for example execution is cruel and
immoral but then no don't kill him let
him suffer and rot in prison seems
hypocritical ok fair question I've
addressed this before I believe that we
should not be focused in terms of
punishments for murderers on what is the
worst punishment I mentioned that in my
opinion rotting in prison for life is
worse than execution only to make the
case that even for those who support the
death penalty because they believe it is
the worst possible punishment I'm saying
even if that's your worldview then it
still makes sense to support life in
prison over the death penalty it's not
an argument I'm making it's an
explanation of why if that's how you
determine what it is that should
designate whether we have punishment a
or punishment B it still would be
consistent to say well life in prison is
worth so I prefer that than execution it
is not my argument so to be super clear
if it were my argument you're right that
there would be a hypocrisy there but I'm
merely saying if your approach is not is
it moral for the government to be doing
this is it moral to have a policy of
punishment that cannot be undone when we
know that there are innocent people on
death row right if your view is not any
of those things but just what is the
most severe punishment it's my opinion
that sitting in prison for life is a
worse punishment but that is not how I
am determining whether it is okay or not
to have the death penalty so it was that
the question is any are people happy now
because it's just becoming a major major
a distraction in the chat and I feel
like people have just been been really
focused on me answering that question
which I now have alright so thank you
very much okay what is coming up on the
David Pakman show we've got awesome
awesome stuff happening on the show
number one political correctness we are
doing a long-form piece on political
correctness in the United States when we
did a piece on the truth about the
gender pay gap I thought it was a very
fair piece and well researched piece a
lot of people didn't like it on both
sides many people but ideologically
committed to the idea that there is no
gender pay gap we found that that wasn't
true
many people ideologically committed to
the idea that women make 77 cents for
every dollar that men make we found out
that that is not true we determined that
the pay gap is roughly that women are
making 90 to 91 cents for every dollar
that men make for the same work and that
some portion of that nine or ten cent
discrepancy certainly could be
attributed to gender bias and
discrimination that's what the data
showed when we looked into it and did a
long-form piece many people didn't like
that okay we are going to be doing a
piece on same applies by the way to our
piece on the regressive left to our
piece about rather aslan to our piece
about undocumented immigration just a
lot of people saying David it sounds
like you're just wrong and whether it's
because we were too far to the left or
right a lot of people didn't like those
videos but those videos are also some of
the most liked pieces that we do we are
currently working on a piece about
political correctness and I think that
it is very likely that the reaction to
this piece will also be anger and
insults and calling me a [ __ ] because
I've talked about political correctness
in the United States many times for
several years and my views on it I
believe are relatively nuanced on the
one hand I am against the suppression
of speech and when I say the suppression
of speech I'm not talking about a
governmental infringement on First
Amendment rights I'm talking about the
colloquial suppression of speech and it
could be anywhere from academic
institutions or in media or wherever I'm
against the suppression of certain types
of speech based merely on the concept
that the answers to the questions being
asked could be offensive right so I
think that any faith-based belief any
religious belief we can't shy away from
examining whether it is corroborated by
anything in sort of the fact-based world
because it might offend someone I'm
against that right I am against having
uh having conversations about what any I
mean it's just just anything I've said
very clearly I'm not a safe space guy
I'm not really a trigger warning guy I'm
not someone who is a sort of moral
relativist where any idea is just as
valid as any other idea any epistemology
is just as valid as any other
epistemology and sort of ascertaining
truths about the world we live in so
when I say that I will often get
feedback from some on the left to say
David you're being insensitive
you're being offensive etc at the same
time I don't actually think that
overbearing political correctness is a
major problem in the country at large
many times I will have conversations
with individuals who say too much
political correctness in this country we
just we can't talk about anything
anymore really my first question is what
is it that you feel you can't say
because of political correctness and
more often than not the answer is either
you know what there's actually nothing I
really feel like I can't say or the
things I feel like I can't say because
of political correctness are insults
racial slurs epithets etc if your
complaints about overbearing political
correctness are merely that it's seen as
inappropriate or look down upon to be
deliberately insulting to large groups
of people
then I would argue that we don't have a
problem with overbearing political
correctness so when you hear both of
those views typically I get a lot of
very angry people on both sides who
email me and we are going to do a
long-form piece into political
correctness I think it's going to be
absolutely tremendous it's going to be
beautiful the way Donald Trump likes to
say and I look forward to telling you
when that is coming up as soon as we
have a date scheduled for it tomorrow on
the program I'm going to be interviewing
Gordon Leigh fur Gordon Leigh fur has
written a book called the 1% solution
how corporations are remaking America
one stay at a time and it's a book about
both states rights but also the way in
which corporations are taking control of
so many aspects of the of state
government and what happens at the state
level on a day to day basis going to be
fantastic
next Monday I'm going to be interviewing
Christopher Voss and do I have his book
here no I don't Christopher Voss is
author of the book never split the
difference and he's a former FBI
negotiator hostage negotiator this guy
has been in some extreme extreme
situations negotiating the release of
hostages and he wrote a book about
negotiation and we're going to be
interviewing him on Monday and Tuesday
it's going to be a two-part interview
it's going to be extraordinary as my
prediction and then on Wednesday we're
going to be speaking to attorney
Arthur Bryant if you haven't heard about
what's going on with Remington firearms
okay you're going to want to tune in to
the interview with Arthur Bryant
there have been spontaneously firing
Remington firearms there has been a
major effort to cover it all up this has
led to a father testifying against his
own kid in a case it's insane what's
going on with Remington and this is
something that I learned about actually
at the masked courts made perfect
conference that I attended in Las Vegas
last week so we're going to talk to
Arthur Bryant next week and then we're
going to round out the interviews next
week by talking to Susan Bordeaux who
wrote a book the destruction of Hillary
Clinton and it's a pretty interesting
post mortem on a lot of what we saw
during the
sixteen election and I think you're
going to enjoy that as well so there's a
lot of really really interesting stuff
that we're going to be doing next week
on the program and then further ahead I
think you're going to like this for a
long time many of our viewers have been
saying David you should really have
Michael Shermer on the show skeptic and
I don't even know how else to describe
him but known skeptic Michael Shermer is
booked on the program he's going to be
joining me for a two-part interview not
next week but the following week and I
think that that's going to be really
good it's someone that we've been
targeting for a while and they actually
got in touch with us we're also going to
be interviewing there's I think I'll
stop there because now we're getting
like three weeks out but there's really
really good stuff coming up on the David
Pakman show let me get to a couple of
other super chats Jeni geser sent a $20
super chat saying silly question David
but here it is why do people pick and
choose when execution is worse than
prison forever for example execution is
cruel and immoral but then don't kill
him and let him rot in prison seems
hypocritical
okay well that I answered that question
so I guess Jennie was passing along the
question from what a [ __ ] and I did
answer it so I'm not I guess I shouldn't
really answer again because I did that
Chris at sig has sent a five-dollar
super chat with no question or comment
thank you Chris and then Jenny geser
with a $10 super chat forget the last
super chat consider it a donation I was
too slow by the way I sent you a
question on the website regarding your
thoughts on psych we at psychiatric laws
hope you get around to that topic one
day soon I didn't see it we get so many
submissions through the contact form
that it is often incredibly difficult to
keep up with it but I will go back and
search for it I'm looking for it here um
yeah I will I will look for that I
promise and see what you had to say
there
um okay let's see what else did I want
to get to there are a couple other
things there every time I do one of
these live streams there's a lot of
people in the chat saying Oh David you
should do this show you shouldn't do
that show this this show is terrible
that show is great this show is terrible
talk about TYT talk about kolinsky jimmy
dore etc and you know the purpose of
these live streams is not really to slam
other shows so I know that there's
there's often people who want me to draw
some kind of line in the sand and
deliberately create some kind of a
problem with another host or something
like that but that's not not exactly
what I'm looking to do on these live
streams what I am looking to do is give
credit where credit is due to just
fantastic people in our audience and
we've had a number of people who have
signed up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership while I've
been talking most of them using the 40%
discount code I voted 17 that includes
Laura McKay that includes Alex
Hildebrand
that includes Devon ducharme that also
includes let me scroll down here see who
else has signed up a Brian Mays has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership maria Kelly has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership so
thank you that particularly in the wake
of the YouTube advertiser boycott we are
extra mostly supported and funded by
viewers and listeners through the
membership program every single weekday
we deliver a radio show and a television
show and a podcast and an online show to
200 radio and television stations that
would absolutely not be able to afford
the program if we had to charge for it
and people who sign up for membership
are helping to cover those production
costs and helping to cover staff
salaries and the cost of renting our
studio and connectivity and storage
space online and all of these different
day to day expenses that we have and I
have no qualms whatsoever
listen whether you need to or not feel
free to use the coupon code
I voted 17 when you sign up you'll get a
40% discount I'd rather you sign up at a
40% discount than not at all because we
do every single dollar counts every
single dollar counts and on that note we
also have had a number of new patrons
pledging even if it's just a dollar a
month it makes a difference a dollar a
month goes a long way and if we could
have just you know 1% of our YouTube
subscribers make a pledge at patreon.com
slash david pakman show we would make up
for so much of the lost YouTube revenue
and this is what a lot of people don't
get and it's a sad thing and I know that
when it comes to this stuff sometimes it
occurs to me as well and I know it
occurs to other people when you see that
there's an opportunity to pledge or
contribute something too many people say
because I can only do a dollar - I'm
just going to do nothing because a
dollar is kind of like nothing that
could not be further from the truth when
it comes to this and we have 817 people
currently pledging $2 a month that adds
up to a lot of money right just the $2 a
month pledges represent 19 thousand
dollars for the entire year imagine if
everybody who could donate $2 actually
did it
this entire YouTube ad crisis would be
over almost as quickly as it began all
right so a lot of thank yous to people
who nearly 1,500 people at this point
who have been pledging thanks to
Kristina Clark who has just pledged at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
thanks to margaret garcia who has also
pledged at patreon.com slash david
pakman show keep those coming and I will
keep the thank yous going because it
really really is just so important so
important and the math of it I mean it's
you know I don't know if people are
surprised when I say I estimate that
between 1 and 1.5 percent of our total
audience contribute to anything
financially and I don't say this as a
criticism I love the fact that people
can contribute contribute what they can
and people who can't still get the
entire show right the show is not here
only for people who can pay we've been
producing this show for everybody for
years and years but when you hear that
only one to one and a half percent of
our audience contributes and this is
sort of across all of our platforms
think about what it would mean if we
could go from one to one-and-a-half
percent to 3 percent of our audience
contributing we've got 300 and how many
thousand at this point 360 roughly
thousand subscribers on on YouTube and
if only if only we were able to go from
one to three percent support that would
be an absolute game changer hey let me
mention this again I know that someone
is messing with me at this point
just about every time I do a live stream
at some point during the live stream I
get phone calls repeated phone calls
from a restricted number okay this is
the only time of the week I ever get
calls from a restricted number most of
the telemarketing calls that I get are
not from restricted numbers and I just
got one of those calls from a restricted
number and I think it's someone messing
with me I hope it's actually a friend
where it's okay that they have my number
not someone that has somehow figured out
what my cell phone number is um and I've
actually picked up during the live
streams before and I say hello and
whoever it is just hangs up there's
nobody there so um I don't know uh if
it's a friend of mine please tell me
that you're doing this and that you're
messing with me I've picked up and
there's nobody there and
I don't know what the fun of it is but
yeah every single time I do a livestream
I start getting phone calls from a
restricted number and you know I don't
know I don't know what the game plan is
and if it's going to continue forever I
have a feeling that it might okay thanks
to Patrick EPS who just made a $2 pledge
at patreon.com slash David Pakman show
other stories that I'm looking at for
tomorrow okay I've already told you
we're going to be talking about the FBI
director James Comey is hearing today in
front of a Senate panel we're going to
be talking about Hillary Clinton's
interview where she blamed both Russia
and FBI director James Comey for her
election loss we're going to be going
through some of the whatever happens in
the next few hours or tomorrow with the
red with the healthcare situation we're
going to be talking about that I'm
looking at a story Sean Spicer says that
it's somewhat sad that people are still
talking about the election President
Trump has mentioned the election every
single day for the last week so if it's
sad it's sad that Donald Trump is
talking about the election a woman has
been found guilty for laughing at Jeff
Sessions during his confirmation
hearings she faces a year in prison
we're going to be talking about that I
might be talking about the foreclosure
rate the American home foreclosure rate
has hit a pretty long time low in the
United States and that may make the
bonus show and not the regular show
tomorrow but it's definitely something
that that is pretty interesting to me
Flint Michigan remember Flint Michigan
which has been having just an epic epic
water crisis they now have put eight
thousand people on unnotice for tax
liens for unpaid water bills of course
it's led tainted water that people have
not been paying for so III will likely
talk about that on tomorrow's program
and there's a lot of other stories that
I'm looking at for tomorrow and then
we've still got the Friday show so a lot
is a lot is going on the extreme
wayne has sent a 5 euro super chat David
what do you think about basic income
automation and artificial intelligence
increasingly replace human jobs
unemployment will be a huge problem in
the near future yeah I'm in favor of
basic income or something like it I've
been talking about it for a while today
we actually had part two of an interview
that I did yesterday and today with
economist Richard wolf and we talked
about basic income sort of indirectly we
talked about technological unemployment
I'm super interested and I've been
reporting on the different basic income
experiments that have been done that are
being done in different parts of the
world some have been done in Africa
there's one that's going on in Finland
there's there's a number of them and
fundamentally you know whether whether
it's basic income or something else
we're going to have to rethink the
relationship between humans and work
certainly between work and healthcare
that's a relationship that has been
bogus for a very very long time but
we're going to have to rethink the
relationship between working and and
having enough money to earn a living
rather to to have it to make a living to
have a sort of reasonable existence on
our planet and I think basic income is
one path forward we should delink work
and healthcare we should also think
about rewarding other types of thought
and creativity and productivity that are
not as tied to the paradigm of work that
we see but yeah we're if we don't start
taking very seriously the technological
automation technological unemployment
automation and AI paradigm shift that
we're in the middle of we're going to
have a real proper time let's put it
that way and it's tough to realize when
you're in the middle of rapid change
it's tough to recognize rapid change
when you're in the middle of the rapid
change in many cases and a number of
futurists have talked about this and I
completely agree this is a major problem
it's a problem that we need to be
dealing with in a way that we're not
dealing with and
uh it's you know from a political
standpoint and I spoke about this with
economist Richard wolf today from a
political standpoint during elections
there's not a big incentive to talk
about technological unemployment because
the first candidate to mention it will
be criticized by the other candidate as
being a loser and just basically
admitting that they're not going to
bring jobs back even though we know
Trump's not going to bring jobs back a
lot of those jobs don't exist anymore so
there's very little incentive during
elections for elected officials to talk
about to talk about it and then
afterwards the solution to the
technological unemployment problem is
likely going to take longer than the
average term for an elected official and
that that applies even to presidential
terms but certainly to the two years
that members of the House of
Representatives get at a time so again
there's not much incentive for the
elected officials uh and and it's it's a
major problem I'm glad you brought it up
basic income is a really really big
thing for me and I'm going to continue
talking about it a twenty what is our I
don't know if our is I don't know what
currency ours but a twenty are super
chat from tat lilac who says I'm seeing
more ads on your videos yay okay thank
you that is a good thing we talked
earlier about how we are seeing more ads
than we were seeing during the week of
March 31st they are unfortunately very
low quality ads so right now the YouTube
channel is earning about a third about a
third of what it was earning before the
YouTube advertiser crisis okay let's see
what else we've got going on a bunch of
people saying that they are seeing an ad
right now on the channel we did not
trigger an ad this time but that's
interesting that an ad is playing all
right Ashley D Rolfe says that R stands
for Brazilian rise reaiize or rails
reaiize yeah okay well that's good I
wonder how much that is how much is 20
Brazilian
uh on Google they're called dollars
let's say this is not going particularly
well so 20 Brazilian rail rails I was
right that is about six dollars and 31
cents so a six dollar and thirty one
cent super chat there thank you very
very much I do appreciate that
and big thank you major thank you to
Nicolas Halleck Nicolas Halleck has
signed up I should mention with no
coupon code whatsoever at david
pakman.com slash membership the coupon
code is available if you want it it's
I've Oded 17 we did have other people
sign up with the coupon code including
Libby Piatra wits petra wits I think is
the way to say I'm saying it not
correctly there Alex Cuellar has signed
up with the coupon code as well whether
you use the coupon code or you don't use
the coupon code I don't care signing up
is what we're looking to what we're
looking to to continue building the
program and of course we are continuing
to take pledges at patreon.com slash
david pakman show even if you can only
contribute a dollar a month head over to
patreon compaq minh show if we have
everybody who says to themselves i'm not
going to contribute because i can only
contribute a dollar a month if everybody
who has that thought run through their
head goes to patreon.com slash david
pakman show and makes a contribution
then the youtube advertiser boycott
crisis would be over in mere minutes
mere minutes it would be over so thanks
to everybody who has joined me that is
it for today big show tomorrow glad you
spent some time with me and we're going
to get back into the normal routine of
doing live streams going forward